[Musique]
les achards sont une spécialité se dédia
tic préparés à base de légumes sautés
macérer ou confie la charrette un terme
générique pour désigner un condiment
épicé c'est les marinades à base
essentiellement de carrie et ça cuit ça
cuit au four le cui vraiment dans une
huile très chaude au départ au ca qu au
soleil
les indiens les anglais ont voyagé à
l'île maurice puis à l'île de la réunion
et à madagascar où ils ont introduit ce
condiment encore aujourd'hui dans tout
l'archipel de l'océan indien
on consomme des achards et chacun y met
sa touche plus ou moins épicés ou
rihanna andriambololona originaire de
madagascar lachard accompagne presque
tous les repas mais à madagascar est ce
que les gens à cuisine au quotidien les
achemine tous les maths ou les
en fait les mères de famille quand ils
vont travailler quand elle retourne du
travail le soir même où d'abord au
marché puis au marché on veut vraiment
comme ça qu'ils vont de des petites des
petits tas puis on en prend chacun
combien de combien vous êtes dans la
famille puis la mer
achète ce qui est nécessaire tous les
jours oui en mange avec le riz le mil
dibala ma mère de famille prépare un la
viande mijoté avec des légumes puis ça
c'est l'accompagnement qui va avec
puis après ou bien le quand on était
enfant l'heure du goûter la collation
leur manger du pain avec du achats au
restaurant malgache ça que ça qu on
était grl achard dans presque tous les
plats en jean mais partout dans les
plats des des clients ça qu'il sache où
et non non ils savent pas ils savent
failli c'est juste dans l'eure dans leur
salade puis ils en mangent ils mangent
ils sont agréablement surpris c'est les
gens les apprécient sans reconnaître des
ingrédients c'est parce qu'ils se
rapprochent de roulement des ketchup ou
chat n'est nettement plus connus ici peu
ce qui est salé sucré acide amer comme
est après cuisson sont des condiments
il ya des condiments naturelles et à des
condiments préparer les condiments
naturel c'est le sel poivre le sucre et
tout ça et les condiments préparer
lahontan dans la famille des religions
tombe dans les flammes ou tard d'autres
entonnent ketchup traditionnel si on
veut donner un petit côté exotique à
norrent beauregard alors honte aux noirs
brugger mais à vianne en mai des achards
dessus au moins ça pour bien réussir ses
achats il faut chauffer l'huile faire
brunir les oignons et l'ail
on ajoute ensuite les légumes du chou
des carottes et des haricots verts donc
on met là maintenant on va on peut
mettre de ce thème mais un petit peu de
public
si on leur en étant le seul atout d
après on laisse bien refroidir avant dé
ces zones et le mélange donc là on va
mettre un petit peu de vinaigre
pas plus que ça non pas plus que ça puis
après je veux rajouter un peu de sel
parce que j'ai goûté tout à l'heure on
peut consommer les achards à l'instant
les conserver au frigo ou les laisser
fermenter en émettant dans un pot
stériliser au tac tac rihanna prépare
aussi une autre variété d'achat à partir
d'un légume très prisé dans la culture
malgache la chayotte jean louis thémis
en sert une version plus près de la
tradition malgache
faites vous toujours bah oui oui
justement je suis en train d'enfer en
est le faire des achats à la chayotte
face et la chayotte pour ceux qui savent
pas là c'est ici qu'est c'est une sorte
de courge puis maintenant ce que je vais
faire
puis émincez les oignons je vais faire
sauter les oignons dans une huile très
chaude avec de l'ail du gingembre quand
ça va commencer à colorer un peu je vais
mettre le cari que moi j'ai notre carrie
commercial puis après ça je peux
rajouter de la couleur le poivre vert le
poivre vert de madagascar je vais tout
mélanger ça le vinaigre
je rajoute du temps aussi mais j'ai
toujours les mêmes épices toujours les
mêmes et pis après laisse refroidir
je le mets en pot je le garde pour la
semaine pour le moi même avec tous les
légumes qu'on va récolter
à l'automne on a tout ce qu'il faut pour
faire des bonds à xare faudrait que les
québécois mangent des achats
[Musique]